New York's Attorney General is launching
an investigation after uber admitted it
failed to disclose a massive data breach
for more than a year the ride-sharing
company said yesterday that hackers
stole the personal data of more than 57
million customers and drivers that
includes names email addresses and phone
numbers Carter Evans is in Los Angeles
with how uber handled the breach Carter
good morning good morning you may be
wondering why I took over a year to
disclose the stolen data which it was
legally required to report well the
company's new CEO had the same question
and decided to come clean after recently
learning about the breach which the
company's previous CEO reportedly kept
under wraps
uber decided to steer clear of federal
regulators when it learned to the
widespread hack in 2016 instead of
reporting the incident the
multibillion-dollar company chose to pay
hackers $100,000 to delete the stolen
data it's not known whether the hackers
followed through technology reporter
eric newcomer broke the story for
bloomberg the crazy thing is definitely
that uber didn't tell anyone for more
than a year their belief was okay we'll
pay them they'll delete it everything
will be fine
along with the names email addresses and
phone numbers hackers also obtained
around six hundred thousand license
numbers from uber drivers in a statement
uber says it's outside forensics experts
have not seen any indication the trip
location history credit card numbers
bank account numbers social security
numbers or dates of birth were
downloaded this incident is going to
give any sort of reasonable person pause
about how much they can trust the
company at the time of the hack goober
was already under investigation for
privacy violations while dealing with
the troubled tenure of embattled CEO
Travis kalanick in a blog post Tuesday
Uber's new CEO Derek ozra Shahi wrote
none of this should have happened and I
will not make excuses for it we are
changing the way we do business
darah the new CEO is trying to clean
things up but it's going to take time he
needs to recruit new leaders and really
change the culture and
that's a big project now uber has fired
a security executive and one other
executive we reached out to former uber
CEO Travis kalanick but have not heard
back
Gale alright thank you very much Carter